[Music]
who
is
ogre
ogre is the boss from tekken 3. yes he
was uh his you know like a lot of
characters have the subtitles paul hot
blood american lee silver hair demon
ogres was the god of fighting
so
tell me a little bit more i know you
know more about this older character
than i do all i know is i think that
ogre killed john kazama and i'm still
mad about it i'm honestly i mean i know
orada gave us the she's just missing but
until i see the body man this dude
definitely killed her i mean there was
an excavation site in central america
and according to the stuff that was on
the wall there heihachi's team was
excavating and they found out like hey
the god of fighting rests here and it
was interesting because
this character once he was unleashed he
started hunting different characters in
the tekken world and you can see that he
has borrowed techniques from different
characters he had some of anna's moves
he had some of armor king's moves he had
some of banks moves right
the battle with ogre took the lives of
some june kazama went missing after her
encounter with ogre right and that's one
of the things that we see kind of like
in the intro for some of the games
he battled that with every other
character i don't know which characters
he's killed or if he's killed any but
obviously he overwhelmed a lot of them
and kind of absorbed their skill and
heihachi was after that power because he
couldn't get the devil gene and couldn't
control the devil gene his goal was to
get the power of ogre and you could see
in yoshimitsu's ending i think it was
where he was able to obtain a vial of
ogre's blood and dr boscanovich was even
experimenting with it they put it into a
rat that rat grew yeah
that's just like a snippet of what that
power is from ogre but ogre again a dtr
or a god of power of a fighting i think
one of the most badass characters that
we've ever seen personally
my favorite outside of like my
characters that i like my favorite
character to use i always thought at
least in tech and tag in tekken 3 that
ogre won and true ogre
so powerful and so fun to play i'm one
of those guys i like really broken stuff
but man actually that's the first really
uh
aside from maybe kazuya to devil in
tekken 2 the first real transformation
character that we've seen because kazuya
and devil were kind of like the same
size and scale but seeing the first
iteration of ogre transform into true
ogre in second three when you get to the
final round that was crazy that was
insane actually pretty sick against the
horns he gets the flame yeah gets the
snake arm yes yeah the unblockable snake
on them that was crazy yeah no no that's
definitely true yeah ogre was definitely
one of my favorite like just bosses in
general especially with like a little
bit of the story you just told me just
now and just how it rounds up because i
feel like tekken does a really good job
of making sure the characters stay
within that realm
[Music]
my
[Music]
you